Have you ever tried BBQ on BBQ? Picture this. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky barbecue glaze and topped with a creamy barbecue sauce. Can't picture it? Well you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. On the 4th of August 2002, best friends Holly Wells and Jessica Chapman disappeared from the small town of Soham in England. One of England's biggest ever manhunts followed. After two weeks the media was critical of police and they perceived lack of progress on the case. But the police did have a suspect. The police found out that Jessica Chapman and Holly Wells were both in the small town of Soham in the county of Cambridge, England. The population of Soham was around 8,500 people. It is a small town in the small town of Soham, England. The population of Soham was around 8,500 people. It is a small town in the small town of Soham, England. The population of Soham was around 8,500 people. It is a small, charming, beautiful town. Jessica and Holly met when they were just four years old. They struck up in instant bond. They were always playing together and were described as being more like sisters.
你尝过烧烤味的烧烤吗？想象一下。新鲜出炉、外酥里嫩、带有调味料的炸鸡，裹上烟熏烧烤酱，再浇上香浓的烧烤酱。想象不出来？现在你可以在蒂姆餐厅品尝到了。快来限时享用我们全新推出的烧烤味脆皮鸡饭碗和卷饼吧。2002年8月4日，好朋友霍莉·韦尔斯（Holly Wells）和杰西卡·查普曼（Jessica Chapman）从英国索ham（Soham）小镇失踪。随后，英国历史上规模最大的搜寻行动之一展开了。两周后，媒体开始批评警方，认为他们在案件进展上明显缺乏成效。但警方确实有一个嫌疑人。警方发现，杰西卡·查普曼和霍莉·韦尔斯当时都在英国剑桥郡索汉姆的小镇上。索汉姆的人口约为8,500人。这是一个小镇，在英国索汉姆的小镇上。索汉姆的人口约为8,500人。这是一个小镇，在英国索汉姆的小镇上。索汉姆的人口约为8,500人。这是一个小巧迷人、美丽的小镇。杰西卡和霍莉四岁时就认识了。她们一见如故。她们总是一起玩耍，被形容为更像是亲姐妹。
Jessica was the youngest of three girls. She was well behaved and a lively child, a healthy outdoors type, a bit of a tomboy. She liked to play sports. She had a bubbly personality and was very friendly and chatty. Holly was more of a feminine type. She enjoyed dressing up, dancing and playing with makeup. Although she did like sport as well, she wasn't as into it as Jessica. She was also bright, bubbly and very intelligent, always smiling and happy. Both girls were 10 years old and were considered sensible and mature for their age. Both were only allowed to visit homes of friends who their parents knew. Jessica had a mobile phone and would keep in regular contact with her mother whenever she was away from the house. On Sunday the 4th of August 2002, Jessica was at Holly's house, where Holly's parents were hosting a barbecue for some close friends. About 5pm the girls decided to dress up in identical clothing. So they both put on red Manchester United jerseys and matching black shorts. Holly's mother Nicola saw them dressed up the same and took a photo of them in their matching outfit. Both girls were committed Manchester United fans, mainly due to the fact their favourite player David Beckham was in the side.
杰西卡是三个女孩中最小的一个。她表现良好，是个活泼的孩子，喜欢户外活动，有点像个假小子。她喜欢运动。她性格开朗，非常友好健谈。霍莉则更有女性气质。她喜欢盛装打扮、跳舞和玩化妆品。虽然她也很喜欢运动，但没有杰西卡那么热衷。她同样聪明、活泼、机智，总是面带微笑，快乐开朗。两个女孩当时都是10岁，在这个年纪被认为是很懂事、很成熟的。她们只被允许去父母认识的朋友家里玩。杰西卡有一部手机，只要不在家，就会经常与母亲保持联系。2002年8月4日星期日，杰西卡在霍莉家，霍莉的父母正在那里为一些亲密的朋友举办烧烤派对。大约下午5点，两个女孩决定穿上一样的衣服。于是她们都穿上了红色的曼联球衣和配套的黑色短裤。霍莉的母亲尼古拉（Nicola）看到她们穿着一样的衣服，就为她们拍了一张穿着配套服装的照片。两个女孩都是坚定的曼联球迷，主要是因为她们最喜欢的球员大卫·贝克汉姆在球队里。
About 5.30pm the girls decided they were bored of the barbecue and went for a walk. They left Holly's house and walked towards the centre of town. They stopped in at a shop to buy some lollies. Then walked down towards the vacant Soham Village College, which is a high school, kids aged 12 and up. Police were able to reconstruct this particular part of the girls walk from CCTV cameras and witnesses. They were both still dressed in their identical Manchester United outfits, so people remembered seeing them. When they got to Soham Village College, they made their way to the caretakers house, where their favourite teacher Maxine Carr lived, with her fiance, Ian Huntley. The girls weren't students at the college, they were still in primary school at St Andrews, which was next to the college. And St Andrews is where Maxine Carr, aged 25, worked.
大约下午5点30分，两个女孩觉得烧烤很无聊，便出去散步。她们离开霍莉家，朝着镇中心走去。她们在一个商店停下来买了一些棒棒糖。然后向闲置的索汉姆村学院（Soham Village College）走去，这是一所高中，招收12岁及以上的孩子。警方通过闭路电视监控和目击者，还原了女孩们这段特殊的散步路线。她们当时都还穿着一样的曼联服装，所以人们都记得见过她们。当她们到达索汉姆村学院时，她们径直走向看门人的房子，她们最喜欢的老师马克西恩·卡尔（Maxine Carr）和她的未婚夫伊恩·亨特利（Ian Huntley）就住在那里。女孩们不是该学院的学生，她们还在圣安德鲁斯（St Andrews）小学上学，该校就在学院隔壁。圣安德鲁斯小学正是25岁的马克西恩·卡尔工作的地方。
She was a teacher's assistant, not an actual teacher, but the girls loved her. She was popular with all the students. Maxine's fiance, Ian Huntley, aged 28, was the caretaker at Soham College, so that's why they lived together in the caretakers house. The girls got there around 6.30pm. Ian Huntley was out the front washing his dog. The girls chatted to Ian and he says that they asked if Maxine or Miss Carr, as they referred to her, was around. Ian told them she was up taking a bath as she wasn't feeling well. The girls asked him if Maxine got the permanent teaching position at St Andrews that she had applied for, and they were disappointed to learn that she hadn't, and she wouldn't be returning to St Andrews after the summer break. The girls told Ian to say hello to Miss Carr for them, and then he says he saw them skip off happily down the road. At 8pm, the girls still hadn't arrived home.
她是一名助教，不是真正的老师，但女孩们都很喜欢她。她在所有学生中都很受欢迎。马克西恩的未婚夫伊恩·亨特利28岁，是索汉姆学院的看门人，所以他们才一起住在看门人的房子里。女孩们大约在傍晚6点30分到达那里。伊恩·亨特利正在门前洗狗。女孩们和伊恩闲聊，伊恩说她们问马克西恩或者她们口中的卡尔小姐是否在附近。伊恩告诉她们，她上楼洗澡去了，因为她身体不舒服。女孩们问他马克西恩是否得到了她申请的圣安德鲁斯学校的固定教职，得知她没有得到这份工作，并且在暑假后不会回到圣安德鲁斯时，她们感到很失望。女孩们让伊恩代她们向卡尔小姐问好，然后伊恩说他看着她们高高兴兴地蹦蹦跳跳着沿着路走远了。晚上8点，女孩们仍然没有回家。
Nicola tried to call them so they could come home and say goodbye to the guests of the barbecue as it was finishing up, but she didn't get an answer. Nicola started to become concerned. She searched every room of the house, then ran outside and looked up and down the street, then ran back inside and searched every room of the house again. There was no sign of them. By 8.45pm, Nicola and Holly's father Kevin thought something was seriously wrong. Holly and Jessica knew they had to be home by 8.30, no matter what. Nicola called Jessica's mother, Sharon, and got the bad news. The girls weren't there either. Sharon became immediately alarmed. She called Jessica's phone, but the phone was switched off. She tried again and again many more times, but the phone remained off. Sharon became panicked. She frantically started to call friends and family members, but no one had seen the girls.
尼古拉试图打电话给她们，好让她们回家跟烧烤派对的客人道别，因为派对就要结束了，但她没有得到回应。尼古拉开始担心起来。她搜查了家里的每一个房间，然后跑到外面朝街上张望，接着又跑回屋里，把每个房间重新搜了一遍。毫无她们的踪迹。到了晚上8点45分，尼古拉和霍莉的父亲凯文（Kevin）觉得情况严重不妙。霍莉和杰西卡知道无论如何她们必须在8点30分前回家。尼古拉给杰西卡的母亲莎伦（Sharon）打电话，得到了一个坏消息。女孩们也不在那里。莎伦顿时感到惊慌失措。她给杰西卡的手机打电话，但手机关机了。她一次又一次地拨打，但手机依然关机。莎伦慌了神。她发疯似地开始给朋友和家人打电话，但没有人见过这些女孩。
Both her and Jessica's father, Leslie, immediately went out searching for them. They checked everywhere they could think of in town, but there was no sign of them anywhere. After about an hour, they made their way to the Wells's house to see if the girls gave any possible clues as to where they were going, but they gave none. The disappearance was completely out of character for the two well-behaved girls. They'd never done anything like this before. At 10pm, the police were called. They got there pretty quickly and started to arrange search teams to try and find the girls. Police checked in with all their other friends, not only to see if they were there, but also to see if their friends could think of somewhere they would go that their parents wouldn't be aware of, but they got no information to help. News quickly spread around the small town, and a lot of the other town members came out to help in the search. They made their way to the grounds of the Soham Village College to see if they were maybe hiding in the school grounds there somewhere. The caretaker, Ian Huntley, immediately offered his help to assist with the search and unlock the college.
她和杰西卡的父亲莱斯利（Leslie）立刻出去寻找她们。他们找遍了镇上所有能想到的地方，但到处都没有她们的踪迹。大约一个小时后，他们来到韦尔斯家，看看女孩们是否留下了任何关于她们去向的线索，但什么也没有。这种失踪对于这两个听话的女孩来说是绝不可能发生的事。她们以前从未做过这样的事。晚上10点，警方报了案。他们很快赶到，并开始安排搜寻队伍试图找到女孩们。警方联系了她们所有的其他朋友，不仅是为了确认她们是否在那里，也是想看看朋友们是否能想出她们可能会去而父母并不知情的地方，但没有得到任何有用的信息。消息迅速在小镇上传开，许多镇上的其他居民也出来协助搜寻。他们来到索汉姆村学院的操场，看看女孩们是否藏在那里的学校场地里。看门人伊恩·亨特利立即主动提出协助搜寻并为学院开门。
When he learnt what was going on, he realised the missing girls were Holly and Jessica, who he had spoken to only hours before. He immediately told the police they'd walked by his house. At this point in time, he was the last known person to see the girls alive. The search went all throughout the night and went all over town, but there was no trace of Jessica or Holly. The next day, the 5th of August, the huge police operation started to get into full swing. It was called Operation Fincham, which is a random operation named generated by a computer and has nothing to do with the actual case. There were great fears for the girls, given it was completely out of their character to simply wander off. There weren't too many people around town who felt the girls had gone missing of their own volition. The area of Soham was relatively flat terrain, however there were a lot of ditches, streams and rivers that had to be searched.
当他得知发生了什么事时，他意识到失踪的女孩就是霍莉和杰西卡，几个小时前他还跟她们说过话。他立刻告诉警察她们曾从他家门口走过。此时此刻，他是最后一个知道活着见到这些女孩的人。搜寻工作持续了一整夜，搜遍了全镇，但没有发现杰西卡或霍莉的一丝踪迹。第二天，即8月5日，大规模的警察行动全面展开。这被称为芬查姆行动（Operation Fincham），这是一个由计算机随机生成的行动名称，与实际案件没有任何关系。考虑到女孩们绝不可能无缘无故地独自闲逛，人们对她们的安危感到极大的担忧。镇上没有多少人觉得女孩们是自愿失踪的。索汉姆地区的地形相对平坦，然而有许多沟渠、溪流和河流必须进行搜查。
Police divers were called in, but there was a lot of water to be covered, and underwater searching was slow work at the best of times. Soham also had extensive parkland areas, and given it was summer, a lot of the areas were overgrown and contained long grass, so the search wasn't straightforward. Over 500 townspeople volunteered to help search. They were tasked by police and used sticks to poke into the various ditches, hidey holes and long grassed areas to make sure they didn't miss anything. Some searched as long as 16 hours a day. Many held onto the firm belief that Jessica and Holly would be found alive. In the meantime, someone became a ghost town. Parents were too frightened to allow their kids out of the house. Police hoped Jessica and Holly were just on an adventure gone wrong, and they were okay, maybe too scared to come home. They even organised a message from the girls hero David Beckham, encouraging them to return home, and that they weren't in any trouble, and appealing for anyone with information to come forward. By Wednesday, police had searched the entire area of Soham and the surrounding areas. They had received 2,500 phone calls, made 400 door-to-door interviews, and had stopped 700 cars in their effort to find the girls.
警方潜水员被召集前来，但需要搜寻的水域面积很大，而且在平时水下搜寻也是一项缓慢的工作。索汉姆还有大片的公园绿地，而且正值夏天，许多地方杂草丛生、野草很高，因此搜寻工作并不顺利。超过500名镇民自愿协助搜查。他们在警方的指挥下，用棍棒探查各处沟渠、藏身处和高草区，以确保不漏掉任何东西。有些人甚至每天搜查长达16小时。许多人坚信杰西卡和霍莉会活着被找到。与此同时，某个人成了一座鬼城。父母们吓得不敢让孩子出门。警方希望杰西卡和霍莉只是去了一场误入歧途的冒险，她们是平安的，也许只是害怕回家。他们甚至组织了一条来自女孩们的英雄大卫·贝克汉姆的信息，鼓励她们回家，告诉她们没有任何麻烦，并呼吁任何有线索的人站出来。到周三，警方已经搜查了索汉姆整个地区及周边区域。他们接到了2,500个电话，进行了400次挨家挨户的走访，并拦下了700辆汽车，全力寻找这些女孩。
Over 700 police officers were involved. The search included the use of a helicopter with thermal imaging equipment, and the use of a plane from the nearby air force base. But they had found nothing. Four days into the search, police held a press conference and gave what little info they knew. It was here that they mentioned the girls were last seen by Soham College caretaker Ann Huntley, as the girls had walked past his house. Naturally, the media were pretty keen to hear what he had to say. Well, I don't know the girls. I was still on the front doorstep, grooming my dog down, she'd run away and come back a bit of a mess. They just came across and asked how miss Carr was, and she used to teach them at St Andrews. I just said she worked very good, and she hadn't got the job. And they're just as pleased to tell her that we're very sorry, and off they walked in the direction of the library over there. By now, police and the media had based themselves in the grounds of Soham College, and held daily meetings and press conferences there. Ann Huntley and Maxine Carr had both been a big help. As the caretaker of the college, Ann helped set up the chairs for press conferences, and was on hand in case anything was needed.
超过700名警官参与其中。搜寻工作包括使用配备热成像设备的直升机，以及来自附近空军基地的飞机。但他们一无所获。搜寻第四天，警方举行了新闻发布会，公布了他们所知道的寥寥无几的信息。正是在这里，他们提到女孩们最后一次被索汉姆学院的看门人安·亨特利（Ann Huntley）看到，当时女孩们从他家门前走过。理所当然地，媒体非常渴望听听他要说些什么。“嗯，我不认识这些女孩。我当时还在前门廊，给我的狗梳毛，它跑开了一会儿，回来时弄得有点乱。她们只是走过来问卡尔小姐怎么样了，她以前在圣安德鲁斯教过她们。我只是说她工作很好，而且她没有得到这份工作。她们听到后表示很遗憾，然后就朝着那边图书馆的方向走去了。”到目前为止，警方和媒体都把基地设在索汉姆学院的操场上，并在那里举行日常会议和新闻发布会。安·亨特利和马克西恩·卡尔都提供了很大的帮助。作为学院的看门人，安帮忙布置了新闻发布会的椅子，并在需要时随时待命。
He also helped coordinate further searches throughout the school grounds. And once the media learnt the reason Jessica and Holly had gone by the college was to see Maxine Carr, they were eager to talk to her as well. This is something I probably keep for the rest of my life, I think. It's what Holly gave me on the last day of term. She was very upset, because I didn't get my job. And that's the kind of girl she was. She was just lovely. Really lovely. On Saturday the 10th of August, police organised a reconstruction of Holly and Jessica's final walk. Two young actresses were dressed up in Manchester United jerseys and black shorts, and retraced the girl's steps in the hopes that might spark something in somebody's memory. The next day, some sections of the media started to criticise the police and their lack of progress on the case, despite their mammoth effort. Unfortunately, as with a lot of cases of this magnitude, a lot of the calls received from the public were false leads and dead ends, including a lot of false sightings of the girls.
他还协助协调了校园内进一步的搜寻工作。一旦媒体得知杰西卡和霍莉去学院是为了找马克西恩·卡尔，他们也急于采访她。“这可能是我一生都会珍藏的东西，我想。这是学期最后一天霍莉送给我的。她非常难过，因为我没有得到工作。她就是那种女孩。她真的很可爱。真的很可爱。”8月10日星期六，警方组织了一场对霍莉和杰西卡最后一次散步的重现。两名年轻的女演员穿着曼联球衣和黑色短裤，沿着女孩们的足迹重新走了一遍，希望能唤起某些人的记忆。第二天，部分媒体开始批评警方及其在案件进展上的停滞不前，尽管他们付出了巨大的努力。不幸的是，正如许多这个规模的案件一样，公众打来的很多电话都是错误的线索和死胡同，包括许多关于女孩们的虚假目击情报。
This actually led the police making a public appeal for young children not to wear red Manchester United shirts in public, fearing it would create many more false sightings. A profile was made up of the abductor, but it was pretty broad. He was thought to be a local man, probably with previous sex offences, aged between 25 and 40. There were around 700 men with prior sex offences living within a reasonable distance of so on. Both the police and Holly and Jessica's parents made direct appeals to the abductor through the media to return the girls home. This included an appeal by police urging the abductor to get in touch by midnight, and that instructions had been left on Jessica's phone via a way of text message. This was an attempt to try and get the abductor to turn on Jessica's phone, which was still off, so they could get a signal on it and try and trace the location. But it didn't work. The phone remained off. Despite the perceived lack of progress from the eyes of the media, the police had a suspect, and they'd been working hard on him behind the scenes.
这实际上导致警方公开发出呼吁，要求幼儿不要在公共场合穿红色的曼联球衣，担心这会引发更多虚假目击。警方绘制了绑架者的侧写，但范围相当广泛。人们认为他是一名当地男子，可能曾有性犯罪前科，年龄在25岁至40岁之间。在索汉姆附近居住着大约700名有前科的性犯罪者。警方以及霍莉和杰西卡的父母都通过媒体直接呼吁绑架者将女孩们送回家。这包括警方的一项呼吁，敦促绑架者在午夜前取得联系，并且已经通过短信的方式在杰西卡的手机上留下了指示。这是为了试图让绑架者打开杰西卡的手机（当时手机仍然关机），以便他们能够追踪到信号并尝试定位。但没有成功。手机依然关机。尽管在媒体眼中进展似乎停滞不前，但警方确实有一个嫌疑人，并且一直在暗中对他进行深入调查。
The police say that the answer is here in Soham. Do you agree with that line of inquiry, as they say? Yeah, absolutely. I mean, for two girls to go missing, basically from our front doorstep, somebody would have seen or heard something if somebody had tried to get those girls into a car, if it had just been somebody passing through. Yeah, it's very strange. By now, Ian Huntley had been identified as a suspect, and police had poured over every word both he and Maxine Carr had added to the media. And there was a lot to pour through. Both were very willing to speak to the media throughout the investigation. The media regularly attended their house looking for interviews. Being the last person to see the girls and being the reason the girls were there was a big deal. The police turned up at their house regularly presenting for what they made look like friendly chats, but each time they would go over his story again and again in the hope he would slip up. And it wasn't missed by anybody just how sparkling clean the inside of their house was.
警方说答案就在索汉姆。你同意他们这种调查方向的说法吗？“是的，绝对同意。我的意思是，两个女孩失踪，基本上就在我们家门口，如果有人试图把这些女孩弄上车，或者如果只是某个路过的人，肯定会有人看到或听到什么的。”是的，这非常奇怪。此时，伊恩·亨特利已被确定为嫌疑人，警方仔细研读了他和马克西恩·卡尔向媒体发表的每一句话。有大量内容需要仔细梳理。在整个调查过程中，两人都非常愿意接受媒体采访。媒体经常去他们家寻找采访。作为最后一个见到女孩们的人，而且是女孩们去那里的原因，这是一件大事。警察经常出现在他们家门口，进行看似友好的闲谈，但每一次他们都会一遍又一遍地核对他的证词，希望能让他说漏嘴。而且大家都没有错过他们家里内部是多么的一尘不染。
But all they had was suspicion. Neither had a criminal record. There was no physical evidence. As the days went on, analysts were able to narrow it down to a much more precise location where Jessica's phone was switched off, and they were able to determine it was switched off somewhere very close to Ian and Maxine's residence. This led police to scrutinise them more closely. And they dug up that in 1998, only a few years prior, Ian had been charged with the rape of an 18 year old girl. But the charge had later been dropped. That's why it wasn't showing up on a criminal record. Also calls had started to come in. Maxine had given a version that she was home the night the girls disappeared, having a bath upstairs that she wasn't feeling well, so she didn't see them. But there were several witnesses from the Grimsby area that said otherwise. They contacted police to say Maxine was in Grimsby visiting her mother the night the girls disappeared. She was spotted by many people out on the town. She was drunk. There was no way she was having a bath at home when the girls came round to visit.
但他们拥有的仅仅是怀疑。两人都没有犯罪记录。没有任何物证。随着时间的推移，分析人员能够将杰西卡手机关机的地点缩小到一个更加精确的范围，并且他们能够确定手机是在距离伊恩和马克西恩住所非常近的地方关机的。这导致警方对他们进行了更仔细的审查。他们查出在1998年，也就是仅仅几年前，伊恩曾被指控强奸一名18岁女孩。但该指控后来被撤销了。这就是为什么它没有显示在犯罪记录上的原因。此外，开始有电话打进来。马克西恩曾提供过一种说法，即女孩们失踪当晚她在家里，在楼上洗澡，因为她身体不舒服，所以没有看到她们。但有几个来自格里姆斯比（Grimsby）地区的目击者却给出了不同的说法。他们联系警方称，女孩们失踪当晚马克西恩在格里姆斯比看望她的母亲。许多人在镇上看到了她。她喝醉了。当女孩们上门探访时，她绝对不可能在家洗澡。
On the 15th of August, police organised a town meeting designed to rattle Huntley. The meeting was held at the college hall, so Huntley helped set it up. Police made it clear that the key to the case lay within the Salem community. They asked the question, was anyone doing anything differently? They encouraged people to look suspiciously at their neighbours and to ask themselves, how well did they really know certain people? The next day the police made their move. They knocked on Huntley's door and asked both he and Maxine if they would like to go down to the station to answer some questions. They both went willingly, not under arrest at this stage. They were taken to two separate police stations to be interviewed, but no cracks emerged. They stuck solid to their stories. Police told Maxine they had witnesses placing her in Grimsby on the evening of the 4th, but she didn't crack.
8月15日，警方组织了一场旨在给亨特利施压的镇民大会。会议在学院大厅举行，所以亨特利帮忙布置了会场。警方明确表示，案件的关键在于索汉姆社区内部。他们提出了这样的问题：是否有人在做着与以往不同的事情？他们鼓励人们以怀疑的眼光看待邻居，并扪心自问：自己对某些人到底有多了解？第二天，警方采取了行动。他们敲响了亨特利的大门，问他和马克西恩是否愿意去警察局回答一些问题。两人都很乐意地去了，当时并未被捕。他们被带到两个不同的警察局接受讯问，但没有露出破绽。他们对自己的供词坚信不疑。警方告诉马克西恩，有目击者证明她4号晚上在格里姆斯比，但她没有招供。
At 9.30pm they were reunited in a nearby holiday inn room. Police arranged them to meet there. They still weren't under arrest. Police had bugged the room in the hopes they would slip up. In the meantime other police searched Ayan and Maxine's home. They also searched the college again and found a shed within the grounds that hadn't yet been searched, as Ayan told police he didn't have a key for it. The shed contained the burnt clothing of Jessica and Holly. The clothing wasn't totally destroyed, so you could make out the Manchester United jerseys. Police found the key to the shed in Ayan's house. He had lied about not having one. The clothes were found in a plastic bag. Ayan's fingerprints were found on the bag. It was all but over. Both Maxine and Ayan were arrested soon after, in the early hours of the 17th.
晚上9点30分，他们在附近的一家假日酒店房间里重聚。警方安排他们在那里见面。他们仍然没有被捕。警方在房间里安装了窃听器，希望他们会说漏嘴。与此同时，其他警察搜查了伊恩和马克西恩的家。他们还再次搜查了学院，并在校园内发现了一个尚未搜查过的棚屋，因为伊恩曾告诉警方他没有钥匙。棚屋里有杰西卡和霍莉被烧毁的衣服。衣服没有完全烧毁，所以还能辨认出曼联球衣。警察在伊恩的家里找到了棚屋的钥匙。他说没有钥匙是在撒谎。衣服装在一个塑料袋里。袋子上发现了伊恩的指纹。一切都结束了。不久之后，马克西恩和伊恩在17日凌晨双双被捕。
Police were pretty certain Jessica and Holly were dead, and later that day their worst fears were confirmed. When the girls' bodies were found in a ditch next to the Air Force Base at Lake and Heath, about 17 miles away from Seoul. The girls' bodies were disfigured, blackened and burnt. Maxine and Ayan were subjected to extensive questioning, and police had to apply for warrants to hold them without charge. Although they had a lot of circumstantial evidence, they still wanted to crack their stories. They were eventually able to wear Maxine down a little and get her to admit she wasn't at home the night the girls disappeared, and she was in Grimsby visiting her mother. This destroyed Ayan's alibi. Car says she lied to protect Ayan when she found out he was the last known person to see the girls alive.
警方基本确定杰西卡和霍莉已经遇害，当天晚些时候，他们最担心的事被证实了。女孩们的尸体在距离首尔约17英里处（注：此处原文可能指索汉姆，翻译按语境处理）的莱克和希思空军基地旁的一条沟渠里被发现。女孩们的尸体面目全非、焦黑且被烧毁。马克西恩和伊恩接受了严厉的审讯，警方不得不申请搜查令和拘留令，在不予起诉的情况下继续羁押他们。尽管他们掌握了大量间接证据，但仍希望攻破他们的防线。他们最终成功磨掉了马克西恩的一些心理防线，让她承认女孩们失踪当晚她并不在家，而是在格里姆斯比看望母亲。这彻底摧毁了伊恩的不在场证明。卡尔说，当她发现伊恩是最后一个活着见到女孩们的人时，她撒谎是为了保护伊恩。
She knew he would be a suspect, especially when police found out he had been charged with rape a few years earlier. She said she gave the alibi not because he was guilty, but to avoid him being suspected unfairly. As far as she was concerned, Ayan was not responsible for the girls' deaths. But her actions suggested otherwise. If you remember back to that earlier media clip, she referred to the girls in the past tense, as she did in several other media interviews. When at that stage, no one knew if the girls were still alive or not. She also helped Ayan scrub the house clean, repeatedly, when she returned from Grimsby. So who were Ayan Huntley and Maxine Carr?
她知道他会成为嫌疑人，尤其是当警方发现几年前他曾被指控强奸时。她说她提供不在场证明不是因为他有罪，而是为了避免他被不公正地怀疑。在她看来，伊恩对女孩们的死不承担责任。但她的行动却表明并非如此。如果你还记得早先的那个媒体片段，她用过去时态指代那些女孩，就像她在其他几位媒体采访中所做的那样。而在那个阶段，没有人知道女孩们是否还活着。她还帮伊恩从格里姆斯比回来后反复把房子擦洗干净。那么，伊恩·亨特利和玛克辛·卡尔到底是谁？
Ayan was bullied at school, described as a class loner. He couldn't make friends, so not even the teachers really liked him. He made one suicide attempt in high school. He left school at 16 and went from one low paying job to another. He moved around a lot to different addresses, and whenever he arrived at a new address, he always lied and talked himself up. He was always making himself out to be better than he actually was. And once people started to catch onto his lies, he would move on to the next address. Ex-girlfriends reported that he was a control freak and liked to dominate and abuse them. After his arrest, many women came forward to detail their horrific experiences with him.
伊恩在学校里经常受到欺凌，被称为班上的独行侠。他交不到朋友，甚至连老师也不怎么喜欢他。他在高中时曾试图自杀过一次。他16岁辍学，从一份低薪工作跳槽到另一份低薪工作。他经常搬家到不同的地址，每到一个新地址，他总是撒谎并自吹自擂。他总是把自己包装得比实际更好。一旦人们开始识破他的谎言，他就会搬到下一个住址。前女友们透露，他是个控制狂，喜欢支配和虐待她们。他被捕后，许多女性站出来详细讲述了她们与他在一起的恐怖经历。
There were several claims of rape, many claims of underage sex, and claims of sexual harassment. There were even claims that he kept girls locked in his flat when they refused to have sex with him. Many were too frightened to report him as he threatened them, but some did. And he was investigated for rape on four occasions and investigated for sleeping with underage girls on three occasions. None of the allegations stuck. There was never enough evidence to charge him, so he never got a criminal record out of it. But there was a clear pattern being established of a serial sex offender. The system bailed by not catching onto it.
有几起强奸指控，许多未成年人性行为指控，以及性骚扰指控。甚至有人称，当女孩们拒绝和他发生性关系时，他会把她们锁在公寓里。许多人因为遭到他的威胁而不敢报警，但也有一些人报了警。他曾四次因强奸接受调查，三次因与未成年少女发生关系接受调查。这些指控最后都不了了之。由于证据从来不够充分而无法对其实施起诉，因此他从未因此留下犯罪记录。但这明显确立了一种连环性犯罪者的模式。司法体制因为没有抓住这一点而将其放纵。
Ian got married just before he turned 21 and subjected his first wife, Claire, to horrendous domestic abuse. He would erupt into fits of rages for no apparent reason and beat her up, leaving her battered and bruised. Claire didn't hang around and left a few weeks later, and she ended up marrying Ian's brother, Wayne. Needless to say, Ian wasn't impressed. It actually caused him to have a breakdown and suffer depression. Claire said he wasn't upset about losing her, but he was upset about losing control of her. That's the type of person he was. Huntley soon went back to his old ways of seducing young schoolgirls. And he did eventually get charged with rape.
伊恩在快满21岁时结了婚，并对他的第一任妻子克莱尔实施了可怕的家庭暴力。他会无缘无故地大发雷霆并殴打她，把她打得鼻青脸肿。克莱尔没有逗留，几周后便离开了，最后她嫁给了伊恩的弟弟韦恩。不用说，伊恩对此很不高兴。这实际上导致他精神崩溃并患上了抑郁症。克莱尔说，他难过并不是因为失去了她，而是因为失去了对她的控制。他就是这种人。亨特利很快重操旧业，去勾引年轻的女学生。他最终还是被指控强奸。
He allegedly followed a drunk 18-year-old girl out of a nightclub one night after she had refused his advances. He raped her and he was arrested and charged a few days later. But after a week of being held in custody, police elected to drop the charges. They believed there was insufficient evidence, leaving the victim furious and leaving Ian still without a criminal record. There was a patent near, horrible violence against women that he kept getting away with, and no wonder his behaviour continued to escalate. Ian met Maxine Carr in a pub in 1998. Ian started chatting her up and there was an instant attraction. The relationship progressed quickly and they were soon living together.
据称，一天晚上，一个18岁的醉酒女孩拒绝了他的追求后，他尾随她走出了夜总会。他强奸了她，几天后被捕并被起诉。但在被关押一周后，警方选择撤销指控。他们认为证据不足，这让受害者愤怒不已，也让伊恩依然没有留下犯罪记录。针对女性的近距离、可怕的暴力行为明显存在，而他却一次又一次逃脱惩罚，难怪他的行为继续升级。伊恩于1998年在一家酒吧遇到了玛克辛·卡尔。伊恩开始和她搭讪，两人一见钟情。这段感情进展迅速，他们很快便同居了。
And it wasn't long before the mental and physical abuse started. But unlike previous partners, Maxine adored the ground Ian walked on and saw his violent controlling behaviour as a sign of his affection and devotion towards her. In textbook domestic violence fashion, Ian would assault Maxine and then profess his love, say he was sorry and he would never do it again, only for the vicious cycle to start again. And it didn't take long before he started cheating on Maxine. With a 15 year old schoolgirl. Maxine found out and attempted suicide. She didn't succeed, but Ian became more attracted to her, thinking she was willing to die for him. Little did he know Maxine was also cheating on him.
没过多久，精神和肉体虐待就开始了。但与前几任伴侣不同的是，玛克辛对伊恩崇拜得五体投地，将他暴力且具有控制欲的行为视为他对她爱意和忠诚的表现。按照教科书式的家庭暴力模式，伊恩会殴打玛克辛，然后宣称他爱她、说他很抱歉而且再也不会这么做了，然而这个恶性循环很快又重新开始。没过多久，他就开始背着玛克辛出轨了。对象是一个15岁的女学生。玛克辛发现后试图自杀。她没有成功，但伊恩却对她更加着迷，认为她愿意为他去死。他并不知道玛克辛也背着他出轨。
They decided their relationship needed a fresh start. They got engaged and moved between several other towns before settling in so on. Ian secured a job as the caretaker at the village college in September 2001. The school was home to around 1300 students. Ian and Maxine moved into the caretakers house. A police check was conducted, but as he had never been convicted of anything, no criminal history came up. In February 2002, Maxine landed a job as a teaching assistant at St Andrews Primary School. She was an instant success with the kids. They loved her, but she didn't get on as well with the teachers.
他们决定两人的关系需要一个新的开始。他们订婚了，并在定居索恩之前在几个不同的城镇之间搬迁。伊恩于2001年9月在乡村学院找到了一份看门人的工作。学校里大约有1300名学生。伊恩和玛克辛搬进了看门人的房子。警方进行了背景调查，但由于他从未被定罪，因此没有查出任何犯罪记录。2002年2月，玛克辛在圣安德鲁斯小学找到了一份助教工作。她立刻受到了孩子们的喜爱。他们很喜欢她，但她和老师们相处得并没有那么好。
Despite his violent history, Ian fit in well with his new job. Other staff didn't have any doubts about his suitability at all. He developed a good relationship with many of the students, mainly the females. He tended to pick on the male students. All in all, Ian and Maxine settled into the town quite well. They didn't make any close friends as they hadn't known their whole lives, but they got on chatting terms with their neighbours, parents of children and local shopkeepers. The attack on Jessica and Holly wasn't planned.
尽管有暴力历史，伊恩还是很好地适应了他的新工作。其他员工对他的胜任能力没有任何怀疑。他与许多学生，主要是女生，建立了良好的关系。他往往喜欢找男学生的麻烦。总的来说，伊恩和玛克辛在镇上安顿得很好。他们没有结交任何挚友，因为他们并不了解彼此的整个人生，但他们与邻居、孩子的家长以及当地的店主都打成了能聊天的关系。对杰西卡和霍莉的袭击并非蓄谋已久。
Ian was a pedophile and it's thought he couldn't resist the opportunity that presented itself when the girls turned up to his house. Maxine was away for the weekend in Grimsby and he had just had a heated argument with her on the phone. He was worried she was cheating on him. And that's when Holly and Jessica showed up. The only person who will ever know the exact story is Ian, but it's thought that when he saw the girls he would have put on his charms and lured them inside on the pretense that Maxine was home and she would be happy to see them. It's thought they were killed soon after the door shut behind them. Although the crime wasn't planned, once Huntley realised the seriousness of what he had done, he became very well planned and organised.
伊恩是一个恋童癖，人们认为当女孩们出现在他家时，他无法抗拒眼前出现的机会。玛克辛当时去格里姆斯比过周末，他刚刚在电话里和她发生了激烈的争吵。他担心她在背叛自己。就在那时，霍莉和杰西卡出现了。唯一一个知道确切故事的人只有伊恩，但人们认为，当他看到这些女孩时，他一定会使出魅力，以玛克辛在家且会很高兴见到她们为借口，将她们哄骗进屋。人们认为她们在身后的门关上后不久就被杀害了。尽管这起犯罪并非预谋，但一旦亨特利意识到自己所做之事的严重性，他便开始进行周密的计划和安排。
He wasn't sorry, but he was terrified of being caught. He thoroughly cleaned the house top to bottom, being sure to move out furniture so nothing was missed. When thinking of where to dispose of the bodies, he knew he couldn't put them anywhere in Salem. He also knew he couldn't travel any great distance. He knew about the airbase in Lake and Heath only 17 miles away as he went plain spotting there and that's where he decided would be a good spot. Plus his grandmother lived in that direction, so if he was spotted out that way there was a reason for him to be there. He put the girls in his car and covered their bodies and made his way to Lake and Heath. When he got there he'd take plastic bags to his feet careful not to leave footprints.
他并不感到抱歉，但他非常害怕被抓。他从上到下彻底清洗了房子，务必把家具搬开，以免遗漏任何东西。在考虑把尸体藏在哪里时，他知道自己不能把它们放在索姆的任何地方。他也知道自己不能去太远的地方。他知道仅仅17英里外莱克和希思的空军基地，因为他去那里看飞机，他觉得那里会是个好地方。此外，他的祖母住在那个方向，所以如果他在那个方向被发现，他就有理由出现在那里。他把女孩们的汽车后备箱里，盖好尸体，朝着莱克和希思驶去。到了那里，他把塑料袋套在脚上，小心不留下脚印。
He cut off their clothing as he knew the clothing would be a means to easily identify the bodies and he didn't want that to happen. He put the bodies in a ditch and then left with their clothing. When he arrived home he put the clothes into a plastic bag and made his way to the shed on the college grounds. He put the clothes in a bin and then set them on fire, but the shed soon filled up with thick smoke so he put it out. The clothes were burnt but they were still largely intact. He didn't light them again scared somebody would see the smoke. He locked the shed up leaving the clothes inside deciding to deal with them later. But he never got a chance due to the constant heavy police presence on the college grounds.
他剪掉了她们的衣服，因为他知道衣服将是轻松辨认尸体的途径，而他不想发生这种情况。他把尸体扔进一条沟渠里，然后带着她们的衣服离开。回到家后，他把衣服装进一个塑料袋里，前往学院操场上的棚屋。他把衣服扔进垃圾桶，然后放火点燃，但棚屋很快充满了浓烟，于是他把火扑灭了。衣服被烧焦了，但大部分仍然完好无损。他不敢再次点燃，害怕有人看到浓烟。他把棚屋锁上，把衣服留在里面，决定以后再处理。但由于学院操场上持续有大量警察巡逻，他再也没有机会。
It became the makeshift base for the police and media. He threw out Jessica's mobile phone. It was never found. After scrubbing himself clean he was able to make his way outside and pretend he had no idea what was going on and he started to help with the search. He knew admitting that he had spoken with the girls would cast suspicion on him but he couldn't take the risk of lying that he hadn't seen them. It was a public place. Somebody could easily have spotted him chatting to them if he got caught lying it would have been all over. The next day he got to work cleaning the car. He got the tyres changed and removed the carpet from the car boot. He called Maxine and begged her to come home early from her trip saying he needed her to lie for him as the girls had come by the house and he would be the prime suspect if she didn't give him an alibi. He then started asking questions of police officers about DNA evidence and how long it lasted which put him straight under suspicion.
这里成了警察和媒体的临时基地。他扔掉了杰西卡的手机。手机一直没有找到。把自己清洗干净后，他得以走到外面，假装自己对发生的一切毫不知情，并开始协助搜寻。他知道承认自己和女孩们说过话会给自己招来嫌疑，但他冒不起谎称自己没见过她们的风险。这是一个公共场所。如果他被抓到说谎，而别人很容易就能看到他曾和她们聊天，那就彻底完了。第二天，他开始清洗汽车。他换了轮胎，并移除了汽车后备箱里的地毯。他打电话给玛克辛，恳求她提前结束行程回家，说他需要她为自己撒谎，因为女孩们曾来过他家，如果她不给他提供不在场证明，他就会成为头号嫌疑人。随后，他开始向警官询问关于DNA证据以及它能维持多久的问题，这让他直接陷入了嫌疑之中。
He became paranoid when he learnt the DNA evidence could last a very long time so he went back to Lake and Heath and set Holly and Jessica on fire. He then embraced his role as searcher. He played a keen part in the search and was often seen as being the unofficial leader of a lot of the search parties that were organised and Maxine was only too happy to help. Lying for Ian and giving him his alibi. The families, the community, the entire country, even parts of the world were stricken with grief as the news Holly and Jessica had been found dead. That grief soon turned to anger. Police had to keep the location of Ian and Maxine's secret as vigilante attacks were a legitimate fear. At Maxine's first court appearance her prison fan was pelted with objects. There was a large crowd yelling abuse and threats and they were banging on the side of the van as it went past. And whilst Maxine was at her first court appearance Ian was in a mental health ward pretending to be crazy. His every move was watched and recorded for 50 days in the hospital. Extensive notes were kept and doctors concluded his mental illness was all a shame.
当他得知DNA证据可以保存很长时间时，他变得偏执起来，于是他回到了莱克和希思，放火烧了霍莉和杰西卡。接着，他重新扮演起搜寻者的角色。他在搜寻中发挥了重要作用，经常被视为许多组织起来的搜寻队的非官方领袖，而玛克辛也乐于帮忙。为伊恩撒谎并提供不在场证明。随着霍莉和杰西卡被发现死亡的消息传出，家属、社区、整个国家，甚至世界各地都陷入了悲痛之中。这种悲痛很快转变成了愤怒。警察必须对伊恩和玛克辛的藏身之处保密，因为私刑袭击是一个真实的恐惧。在玛克辛第一次出庭时，她的囚车遭到物品投掷。现场有一大群人叫骂威胁，并在囚车驶过时拍打车身。正当玛克辛第一次出庭时，伊恩则在精神病房里假装疯癫。在医院的50天里，他的一举一动都被监视和记录。医生们留下了详细的记录，并断定他的精神疾病完全是伪装出来的。
Ian was putting on an act and should be treated like every other suspect. They recommended he be sent back to normal custody. He was taken to prison and was met by a huge amount of abuse and threats from the other inmates. He was placed in a specially made isolated cell where he was kept under close watch. But he still managed a near successful suicide attempt. He had to have an urgent stomach pump but he survived. Maxine was also segregated from other prisoners. She tried to starve us off and at one point she had to be force fed through a tube to stay alive. By the time the trial came around more forensic evidence had come to light. Police had found fibres from the Manchester United jerseys in Huntley's home. They found evidence in his car. Plus they had his prints on the bag the girls jerseys were found in. Maxine and Ian were tried together in the same courtroom. Faced with their overwhelming physical evidence Ian was forced to come up with a story.
伊恩是在演戏，应该和其他嫌疑人一样对待。他们建议把他送回普通看守所。他被带到监狱，受到了来自其他犯人的大量辱骂和威胁。他被安置在一个特制的隔离单人牢房里，受到严密监视。但他还是差点成功自杀。他不得不紧急洗胃，但他活了下来。玛克辛也与其他犯人隔离。她试图绝食，一度不得不通过管子强行喂食以维持生命。到了审判之时，更多法医证据浮出水面。警察在亨特利的家中找到了曼联球衣的纤维。他们在他的车里找到了证据。此外，他们还在装有女孩球衣的袋子上找到了他的指纹。玛克辛和伊恩在同一个法庭上受审。面对压倒性的物证，伊恩被迫编造了一个故事。
He admitted the girls were in his house. He said Holly's nose started to bleed so they walked upstairs to the bath which was full of water as he had been washing the dog. Holly sat on the side of the tub and he accidentally bumped into her causing her to fall and hit her head. Jessica started screaming you pushed her so we rushed over to try and quiet her down by grabbing her around the mouth. Accidentally killing her in the process. He then turned around to find Holly had drowned by accident. Huntley took the stand to give this ridiculous account and the many gaping holes in his story were easily exposed. Ian also testified Maxine didn't know that he was responsible for the girls death and when Maxine testified the next day she said Ian's testimony was the first time he said he was responsible for their death. Until that point she believed he was innocent. But many remain unconvinced.
他承认女孩们曾在他的家里。他说霍莉的鼻子开始流血，于是他们上楼走到浴缸旁，当时浴缸里装满了水，因为他一直在给狗洗澡。霍莉坐在浴缸边缘，他一不小心撞到了她，导致她滑倒并撞到了头部。杰西卡开始尖叫“你推了她”，于是我们冲过去，通过捂住她的嘴试图让她安静下来。在这个过程中意外杀死了她。接着他转过身，发现霍莉已经意外溺水身亡。亨特利走上证人席讲述了这番荒谬的供词，他故事中许多巨大的漏洞轻易地就被戳穿了。伊恩还作证说，玛克辛并不知道他是女孩们死亡的责任人，而玛克辛第二天作证时则表示，伊恩的证词是他说自己是责任人的第一次表态。在那之前，她一直相信他是无辜的。但许多人仍然对此持怀疑态度。
Her explanation for doing several extremely detailed house cleans was that she was a clean freak. And I'm not sure what the reason was that she gave her repeatedly referring to the girls in the past tense. She said Ian begged her to lie for him and provide an alibi as police would think it was him even though he didn't do it. She said she knew it wasn't right morally but she thought it was right for Ian as she didn't want him to be accused of something he hadn't done. There was evidence Ian had been frantically trying to clean the house when Maxine arrived home from Grimsby but she said she believed this was done to try and cover up the fact that he had been cheating on her. She made herself out to be a victim of Ian as well. An unwilling pawn. Who can forget the very dramatic scenes in courtroom number one as Maxine Carr giving her evidence from the witness box broke down as she was questioned and said pointing at Ian Huntley across the courtroom. I will not be blamed for what that thing in that box has done to me all those children.
她对多次进行极其细致的房屋清洁的解释是，她是个有洁癖的人。我不知道她反复用过去时态指代那些女孩的原因是什么。她说伊恩恳求她为他撒谎并提供不在场证明，因为警察会认为凶手是他，尽管他并没有杀人。她说她知道从道德上讲这不对，但她觉得这对伊恩来说是对的，因为她不想让他为自己没做过的事情背黑锅。有证据表明，当玛克辛从格里姆斯比回家时，伊恩一直在拼命打扫房子，但她说她相信这是为了掩盖他出轨的事实。把自己塑造成了伊恩的受害者。一个不甘愿的棋子。谁能忘记一号法庭上那些充满戏剧性的场景：玛克辛·卡尔在证人席上作证时情绪崩溃，在接受质问时指着法庭另一头的伊恩·亨特利说：“我不会为那个盒子里的东西对我、对那些孩子所做的一切背黑锅。”
Ian Huntley was found guilty of murder. He was given a life sentence for age count and was given a minimum term of 40 years. Meaning he would be eligible for a lease in 2042 at 68 years of age. Interestingly the jury wasn't unanimous. It was an 11 to 1 count. Maxine Carr was found guilty of providing a false alibi but not guilty of helping conceal the murder. The jury was satisfied she didn't know Ian had killed Jessica and Holly. Maxine was sentenced to three and a half years jail but she only served one year and nine months. When released from prison Maxine was given a new identity. Her appearance was changed with the help of experts and she was placed in a secret location to live.
伊恩·亨特利被裁定谋杀罪名成立。他因数罪并罚被判处终身监禁，最低服刑期为40年。这意味着他将在2042年、即68岁时才有资格获得假释。有趣的是，陪审团并未达成一致意见，投票结果为11比1。玛克辛·卡尔被裁定提供虚假不在场证明罪名成立，但协助隐瞒谋杀罪名不成立。陪审团认为有充分证据表明她并不知晓伊恩杀害了杰西卡和霍莉。玛克辛被判处三年半监禁，但她实际只服刑了一年零九个月。刑满释放后，玛克辛被赋予了新的身份。在专家的帮助下，她的外貌进行了改变，并被安置在一个秘密地点生活。
Her lawyer successfully got a high court injunction banning the press from revealing her new identity or the location she lived. It basically forbade journalists from even trying to find out this information let alone publish it. She was even given police guards to protect against revenge attacks. And of course all this was done at the expense of the taxpayer. Thanks for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她的律师成功获得了一项高等法院禁令，禁止媒体披露她的新身份或居住地点。这项禁令基本上禁止记者去打听这些信息，更不用说将其公开发表了。她甚至得到了警方派出的保镖保护，以防遭到报复袭击。当然，这一切都是由纳税人出资承担的。感谢观看。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。